my name's Jose Rosado I'm the curatorial Associate
in herpetology at the Museum of Comparative Zoology
at Harvard university
the collection itself it's synoptic informal
we have represent those from around the whole
world
we have probably about ninety percent of
all extinct species represented in the collection
in number there are
approximately three hundred twenty seven thousand
individual specimens in the collection these
collections are used internationally
by researchers all over our job is to basically
curate maintain it and also make sure that
is used is proper and then according to
protocols and procedures i grew up in New
York city i used to enjoy going to the american
museum
on my free time on and very interesting just
animals i use to keep a lot of animals at home etc.
and i spent a lot of time of the meuseum on
my own and always wanted to
to get a job there throughout the whole place
who read this different research departments
and i got introduced to the members of the
herpetology department there and i got interested in it an
eventually I was hired for the summer to work
in the laboratories and take care of the animals
etc. and from then on it was just an interested I
developed uh i'd then decided to a major
in biology and continued from then on I've
been here since July of nineteen seventy seven
so thats about thirty two years
working in this position
it's a great place to work in uh the people
of fascinating that's just not a lot of interesting
things going on here and research itself the
people you meet doing the research the ideas that people come up with
come up etc. new stuff is being uh
discovered an its just fascinating
and so its just like feeds you all time
I think in a way and its just very exciting